[Music]
only time will tell if those skeletons
those bodies will ever see the light of
day again but that's why we felt we had
to pay a visit to Lake Mead no one has
ever done a true paranormal
investigation of this location before so
we're the first team to dive in head
first into the dark Waters of the lake
in an attempt to gather some answers to
these Mysteries but let me warn you be
prepared
what you're about to see will shock you
I grew up in a haunted house so I've
always had a passion for the Paranormal
and I went to film School dropped out of
film school and I found my passion in
ghost hunting and that's how I got here
doing paranormal investigations
full-time across the world on YouTube uh
well we grew up pretty much the same in
a house uh my twin and I and
we dealt with all kinds of hauntings and
kind of just wanted to bring everything
to I guess like a reality and show
everybody the truth and you know try to
gather as much proof as possible
we had been talking about it for quite
some time and we figured you know
it's sort of unorthodox and kind of
outside the box but maybe we should go
down there and give it a shot and see if
uh if we can get any answers for for
some of those people we're here finally
tonight at Lake Mead as we've talked
about lots of murders in this area over
the years experts think that there are
hundreds literally this is in the news
hundreds of bodies in the lake we
specifically chose to the left side of
Hemingway Harbor I believe it was where
the one in the barrel was found that was
kind of our focal point
so
once we are watching the wind and
whatnot we picked our time around 9pm to
start that was when the wind was at its
lowest and we kind of just Cruise out
there without seeing anything beforehand
without knowing too much information
that way whatever we do capture has some
validity to it you know it's not
scripted or planned
and then we get all of our cameras and
devices set up and and start talking we
basically go into these investigations
hoping for the best what if we don't
leave
did you do some horrible things
it'll says drown drown you I'll drown
you shoot
then kill kill
dude right there what if we don't leave
dude oh my God I think we just go and
just ask the the questions you know and
we base what we do next based on the
answers so in the video there's a moment
when Ryan is asking if it can lead the
spirit can lead us to uh where its body
is are you trying to tell us where
there's a body right now
can you maybe try to be more exact more
specific
and on the device it literally says go
right while we were sitting at an
intersection
I'm about to find a body which is I mean
that's just mind-blowing the it's the
timing behind all this stuff it's not
like you know we were asking when did
you die and it said go right or
something like that it was a direct
answer to the question while we were
walking so like you guys said I think we
really were being led to find something
I don't know if it was like it could
have been a murder weapon a body a bone
something like that but we were being
led somewhere for sure
yo coyote there it is yeah yeah you're
yourself will go after one person we
deal with coyotes quite often but never
something like this
[Music]
oh bro
[Music]
we had seen a coyote just one
a bit earlier when we had parked in that
the spot that we wanted to start our
investigation
so we start hearing whimpering and it
seems a little far away but I tell Colin
um man they they like to Target like
people by themselves because I've heard
multiple stories and well we started
hearing more coyotes and more careful
guys
and
closer and closer and so we started to
get pretty much circled in to where we
had to run to the car for safety
get to the car
and it was it was just totally different
than what we've ever dealt with in our
lives
foreign
are there any bodies around us
happened here
oh my God
with the spirit talker with that app
while we were there we got the words
boat water kill bullet multiple times
and those are words that I personally
have never seen ever on an investigation
and we're like right up on the lake on
the water and it's saying boat water
it's crazy and what I really like using
those exact devices
um what we all do is use them all at the
same time and what's interesting is
multiple times while we were at Lake
Mead a word would come through on one
device and two three seconds later
something would trigger the REM pot
which meant that there was this Phantom
energy that came through and gave us the
word and was actually physically there
that we could pick up with the device it
corroborates everything
not thinking you and maybe my face out
here
this is insane man this is dude maybe
there's like a bullet
retaliate
don't do this alone yeah because we
wouldn't have done any of this stuff and
we wouldn't be doing the stuff that we
do outdoors if you want to do it
Outdoors bring somebody also come
prepared because
weird stuff can happen and
be open-minded believe in what you are
looking for because you will find it oh
yeah that's the big one right there it
all depends on the energy you put out
and what what you bring to the location
or to the investigation I think that
really helps with what you get out of it
not not all the fancy toys and gadgets
and stuff like that yeah that's what I
was going to say I think you guys would
agree lots of people get tripped up
thinking they need to have fifteen
thousand dollars of ghost hunting gear
to ghost hunt you really only need
yourself a friend and the experiences
will happen if if you actually do it
that's my advice that I've always told
people that ask me if you want a ghost
hun just do it you got to get out of
your house and actually go to the place
and there you are you're ghost hunting
already whether you have the twenty
thousand dollar thermal camera or not